Captain America premier just lots of big
stars glasses and big fun quick betray I
like I see the world for your Golden
Lion know what yes so Chris snag Carly
shades but here's a surprise he was
actually a little nervous on the red
carpet when you see fans and you know
you kind of shaking in your boots about
it shaking debatable really yeah yeah
it's nerve-wracking but it's exciting
the Marvel Universe has its day of
reckoning in Captain America Civil War
there's a deep divide in the superhero
universe and lectures say Iron Man and
Captain America do not play nice
together
captain you seem a little defensive
what's been a long day Susan Downey is
my entire squad love that especially
after seeing this date night pick our DJ
posted before the big event
speaking of squads we know Anthony
Mackey's got Sebastian Stan on his list
watch him take over Carly's interview
you ever see a guy this handsome walking
the streets he's gonna get arrested
because he's killing all the ladies look
at that
I just let you introduce okay great get
out of here
so what are you wearing tonight I mean
that's a little black on blue on grey on
black I like that Wow you like a paratha
that's not me that's jay-z what do we do
we fight
Robert has that people might be
surprised to hear he has an incredible
skill of making the best this is gonna
sound crazy fast possible he and our son
take the most adventuresome weirdo baths
with like really hurt us
yeah fun bath okay we didn't see that
coming or this